got a special guest here uh a special
gift from chica lopez who just gave 20
and he's listening to this chico this is
a shout out for you we got kobe in the
house what's up little kid toby
oh my gosh it's mine yeah we just got it
last week oh he's so cute oh dude look
at this guy look at this guy you can put
him on the table here let him kick back
a little let's see what he does maybe he
just joins us don't pull a biden
the other two dogs are not big fans can
we put his face up on the camera so
people can see it's so bad for jimbo and
coach right they're not a fan man
he bites them he wrestles them and they
run away they're not
can you put him on the camera tom let's
let's uh
there you go
oh look at that thing
huh
i don't think so i don't know yet but uh
we're in love with this guy man he came
in another one of those things man first
night i'm having a conversation with
mario at midnight i'm like mario i think
i'm gonna give the dog to eric and mario
says pat just sleep on it like here we
go i'm gonna sleep on it for 16 years
that's what's going to happen but
he's with us he's kicking it he's having
a blast
and uh pat when i started kicking it
with you you had three kids and two dogs
now you got four kids three dogs
an even bigger house you got your dad
living with you you know
yeah you you just you said i'm here let
me pile it on are you are you suggesting
to add cats to that or what's like is
there like a maybe you want to have a
cat or two what do you what are you
trying to do
diversify yeah so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]